This is 99% Invisible. I'm Rowan Mars. One of the missions of 99PI is to give you the tools to decode the built world in cities, in the country, and the highways in between. It's those highways and the truckers that drive the American economy, that is the subject, of the new radio-topia show called Over the Road. The podcast is a window into a world that you pass by at 65 miles an hour without giving much thought, but it is so fascinating you will never see a semi-truck
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。99PI 的使命之一，就是为您提供各种工具，去解码城市、乡村以及贯穿其间的公路等我们所身处的人造世界。正是这些公路以及支撑着美国经济的卡车司机们，成为了全新 Radiotopia 节目《在路上》（Over the Road）的主题。这部播客为你打开了一扇窗，让你得以窥探那个你以每小时65英里的速度驶过却鲜少驻足思考的世界，但它是如此迷人，以至于你再也不会用
the same way again. Every 9-9 PI beautiful merchant to describe it is run up here alley. Here's the first episode of Over the Road, hosted by Long Hall Paul. Four years ago, I was northbound on I-75 and Knoxville, Tennessee. My cargo, a load of imported watermelons. They had sailed on a container ship from Guatemala to South Florida, where they were transferred
同样的眼光来看待半挂卡车了。每一个 9-9 PI 美丽的商人来描述它，都被开到了这条巷子里。以下是《在上路上》的第一集，由“长途保罗”主持。四年前，我正驾车行驶在田纳西州诺克斯维尔的I-75州际公路上向北行驶。我的货物是一车进口西瓜。它们坐着集装箱船从危地马拉运到南佛罗里达，在那里被转移到
by forklift on the big trucks driven by folks like me. These were those tiny, seedless, designer types they call personal watermelons. I always wondered about the marketing cat who came up with that one. Personal watermelons. It's like a water melon trailer back then, a reaper as we call them. A reaper is a heavily insulated box trailer equipped with a giant diesel-powered temperature control unit. It's actually got the capacity to maintain more than 40,000 pounds of perishable freight at temperatures as cold as 20 below. It was rush hour in Knoxville, or K-town and trucker code.
由像我这样的人驾驶的大卡车上，使用的工具是叉车。这些就是那种小型的、无籽的、设计感十足的品种，他们称之为个人西瓜。我总是很好奇那个想出这个点子的营销鬼才。个人西瓜。就像当时的一个西瓜拖车，我们称之为冷藏车。冷藏车是一种重度保温的箱式拖车，配备了一个巨大的柴油动力温控装置。它实际上有能力
Traffic came to a screeching halt at the junction of I-75 and I-640. I got stopped in time, but the trucker behind me. Well, not so much. Boom! Shoot! Rear-ended. I took a minute to collect myself and walked to the back of the trailer to check first on the other driver.
在低至零下20度的温度下，保持超过40,000磅的易腐货物。当时正是诺克斯维尔（在卡车司机行话中叫K镇）的交通高峰期。交通在I-75和I-640的交汇处戛然而止。我及时停了下来，但我后面的卡车司机——嗯，可就没那么幸运了。轰！哎呀！被追尾了。我花了一分钟平复了一下心情，然后走到拖车后面，首先去查看另一个司机的情况。
He said he was okay. Then I opened the vent hatch to check my load. What seconds before had been a perfectly picked personal watermelon was now prolapsing through its ruptured rind, down the crumpled exterior of what had once been the trailer's stainless steel door and on to my trembling hand. Sorry, friend. Unbeknownst to me at the time, this baptism in the puree of a personal watermelon would come to be my own creative big bang. Strangely, as a result of this event, I would come to be a part-time recording artist, a contributor for Overdrive magazine, and now even a card carrying podcast-producing radio-tobion.
他说他没事。然后我打开通风舱检查我的货物。几秒钟前还是一个精挑细选的个人西瓜的东西，现在正从它破裂的果皮中脱垂出来，顺着曾经是拖车不锈钢门的褶皱外表往下流，落在我颤抖的手上。对不起，朋友。当时我并不知道，这场个人西瓜果泥的洗礼，后来竟成了我自己的创意大爆炸。奇怪的是，作为这次事件的结果，我成了一名业余唱片艺人，《超速》（Overdrive）杂志的撰稿人，现在甚至成了一名持有证件的播客制作人、Radio-tobion。
I'm Long Hall Paul. You're listening to Over the Road. I got that Lucy, you're Lucy off on Mulpio, come on baby, let's truck it up, do it baby. Now I'm on the top of this mountain and I know I still got to get down the other side somehow and I'm so scared I'm shaking. But I know quite a few drivers that swear by roasting salmon over their engine. We were willing to take a pot-bellied peg, we tried to even pick up a 60 pound tortoise. I love you guys, I have times of change and I need that one anymore, but why shouldn't it be that way?
我是长途保罗。你收听的是《在路上》。我得到了那个露西，你是Mulpio的露西，来吧宝贝，让我们开着卡车出发，干吧宝贝。现在我在山顶上，我知道我仍然得想方设法从另一边下去，我吓得直哆嗦。但我认识不少司机，他们对在发动机上烤三文鱼深信不疑。我们愿意买下一头大肚猪，我们甚至试过捡一只60磅重的乌龟。我爱你们，我有过改变的时期，我不再需要那个了，但为什么不该是那样呢？
I love you guys, I have times of change and ain't that way anymore. But why shouldn't it be that way? Here's how this is going to work. We've been traveling all over the country, down the highways and the hedges, collecting the real stories of real people who live and work over the road. We've got eight episodes for you, and each one we explore how tracking is changing today. And along the way, I'll tell you a few of my own stories, heck.
我爱你们，我有过改变的时期，而现在已经不是那样了。但为什么不该是那样呢？事情将是这样的。我们一直在全国各地旅行，沿着公路和树篱，收集那些在路上生活和工作的普通人的真实故事。我们为你准备了八集节目，每一集我们都在探讨当今的卡车运输业是如何改变的。一路上，我也会讲几个我自己的故事，见鬼。
I might even sing you a few songs. Let's start out at a place called the Kentucky Expo Center in Louisville, home to the Mid-America Trucking Show, or Mats for short. Think of a home depot, about 12 times it's normal size, then fill it with trucks, truck drivers, and every possible thing anyone has ever thought of to make a buck off a trucker. It's an automatic snow chain system, it works good on it. So what we're selling is bedbook heaters for truckers that have cabs. Throw in 90,000 people with some concerts and swag, and you've got the Min America trucking show. You've got your air freshener dudes.
我甚至可能会为你们唱几首歌。让我们从一个叫做肯特基博览中心（Kentucky Expo Center）的地方开始，它位于路易斯维尔，是美国国际卡车展（Mid-America Trucking Show，简称Mats）的所在地。想象一个比正常尺寸大12倍的家居建材店，然后里面塞满了卡车、卡车司机，以及任何你能想到的、能从卡车司机身上捞到钱的奇思妙想。这是一个自动防滑链系统，它在这方面效果很好。所以我们卖的是给带驾驶室的卡车用的卧铺加热器。再加上9万人的演唱会和各种免费小礼品，你就得到了美国国际卡车展。这里有各种空气清新剂老哥。
Older eliminated products for the powwow professional. I love those guys. We say three sprays last for days. Tell me about this beef jerky. You've got those old boys who make the beef jerky. You'll ever eat. You'll have that. That's really tender. I actually love those guys too.
为泡泡专业人士淘汰的产品。我爱死那些家伙了。我们说喷三下能管好几天。跟我讲讲这个牛肉干。你遇到了那些制作你吃过的最棒的牛肉干的老伙计。你会尝到那个的。真的很嫩。其实我也超爱那些家伙。
We are an insurance company that specializes in owner operators. They are the international vendors hoping to land that big contract. I'm so glad. Shonkai was so far. Big truck makers are here, like Kenworth and Peter Bell. We have our new 579 Ultra Loft and it's black. So model truck makers. I'm proud to tell people I can't afford a real one,
我们是一家专门为车主运营商提供服务的保险公司。他们是国际供应商，希望能拿下那个大合同。我太高兴了。Shonkai 迄今为止进展顺利。大型卡车制造商也来到了这里，比如肯沃斯（Kenworth）和彼得比尔特（Peterbilt）。我们推出了全新的 579 Ultra Loft，它是黑色的。还有模型卡车制造商。我很自豪地告诉人们我买不起真车，
but I can hook you up with a real nice toy like. But for many long time, gear jamammers, that signifies something more. It's a hobo convention of sorts, a chance to see old trucking buddies and swap stories, and that's why we're here. If you want to know what's going on in the trucking world, this is a good place to start. But first, let's cover some basics. This is a good place to start. But first, let's cover some basics. There are 4.2 million Americans who hold a CDL. That's a commercial driver's license.
但我能帮你搞到一个非常漂亮的玩具。但对于许多老资历的“挡位发卡员”（老卡车司机）来说，这象征着更多的东西。这有点像一个流浪者大会，是一个见见老卡车司机伙伴并交换故事的机会，这就是我们来这里的原因。如果你想了解卡车运输界发生了什么，这是一个很好的起点。但首先，让我们了解一些基础知识。这是一个很好的起点。但首先，让我们了解一些基础知识。有420万美国人持有CDL。也就是商业驾驶执照。
A CDL allows us to drive a vehicle weighing over 26,000 pounds. Together, we move 70% of all domestic freight. Think of it. Everything you see at the store, everything you buy online, moves by truck at some point. At it all up, we're talking about a $700 billion industry, moving literally 55 billion pounds of stuff every day. At that rate, American truckers could haul off the great pyramid of Giza, stone by stone,
CDL允许我们驾驶重量超过26,000磅的车辆。合力之下，我们承运了全美70%的国内货运量。想想看。你在商店看到的每一样东西，你在网上买的每一件东西，在某个环节都是通过卡车运输的。加起来，这是一个价值7000亿美元的行业，每天实实在在地图运送着550亿磅的货物。按这个速度，美国卡车司机可以把吉萨大金字塔，一块石头接一块石头地搬走，
about five times a day. Of course, there are lots of different types of truckers and trucks out there. We refrigerated freight trucks that call a refit for us. You know, like what I drive. Flat beds, we should call them skateboards. Those big flat trailers with loads of lumber and steel. Call out to the Column Parker Lines. Bedbucker is a furniture hauler.
大约一天搬五次。当然，外面有各种各样不同类型的卡车司机和卡车。我们把冷藏货运卡车叫作 refit（冷藏车）。你知道的，就像我开的那种。平板车，我们应该叫它们滑板。那些装载着大量木材和钢铁的大型平板拖车。向 Column Parker Lines 致敬。Bedbucker 是一名家具运输工。
A tanker truck, we call a tanker-yanker. I drive one of those sometimes too. Talk to the hauler boy they call them boah haulers. I mean there's all kinds of terminology for them. As you can imagine, we have our own factions, cliques and hierarchies. Flatbedders don't usually associate with the rougher guys like me, and the ball-halmers could never see themselves as freight-halmers, or door-swingers as they call them. Because all a door-swinger does is back up to the dock and swing the doors open
油罐车，我们叫它油罐拔河者。有时候我也开这种车。与搬运工男孩交谈，他们称他们为 boah 搬运工。我的意思是，有各种各样的术语来称呼他们。正如你所想象的，我们有自己的派系、小圈子和等级制度。平板车司机通常不与像我这样粗鲁的家伙交往，而散装货运司机绝不把自己视为普通货运司机，或者像他们所说的开门司机。因为开门司机要做的全部事情就是倒车到月台，然后把门推开
and shut. Or so they say. But here, for three days at least, none of that matters. We're all just drivers, and not a one of us came here to have a bad time. Volvo Dynamic Steering with Stability Assist is a new innovation from Volvo Trucks. A lot of the target mats this year is about new technology. When Trucks. Along with the target maths this year, there's about new technology. When a truck starts to skid. It seems every part of the truck has got a computer in it now. Yeah, the suspension seat is turned on.
再关上。他们是这么说的。但在这一连三天里，这一切都不重要了。我们都只是司机，我们这里没有一个人是来找不痛快的。带有稳定辅助功能的沃尔沃动态转向系统是沃尔沃卡车的一项新创新。今年Mats的目标很大一部分是关于新技术的。当卡车。除了今年 Mats 的目标之外，还有关于新技术的内容。当卡车开始侧滑时。现在卡车似乎每个部件里都装了电脑。是的，悬浮座椅已经启动了。
Even the seat. Notice how much of the bouncing is eliminated by the active suspension seat's computer controlled motor. And there's a feeling the technology is not just changing the truck, but it's changing us and the way we do business That the codes and culture of trucking are eroding before our eyes I bump into a Facebook friend on the show floor named Greg Murphy who now works for Uber Facebook friend on the show floor named Greg Murphy, who now works for Uber. Through an arreza man, I figured, oh this is never gonna happen. Yes, the rideshare company Uber.
连座位也是。注意看，主动悬浮座椅的电脑控制马达消除了多少颠簸。人们有一种感觉，新技术不仅在改变卡车，它还在改变我们以及我们做生意的方式，卡车运输的密码和文化正在我们眼前瓦解。我在展厅里遇到了一个叫格雷格·墨菲（Greg Murphy）的 Facebook 好友，他现在为 Uber 工作。在展厅里遇到的 Facebook 好友叫格雷格·墨菲，他现在为 Uber 工作。通过一个 arreza 人，我想，哦，这永远不会发生。是的，拼车公司 Uber。
And here I am. Now Greg, you have a unique story because you are a long-time truck driver. Right, exactly. Who has become like the public relations liaison for Uber, is that? Exactly, kind of the interpreter, I would call it between the trucking community and Uber freight. Greg is affable, middle-aged, with a salt and pepper beard and a cool fedora. More truck driver than computer person, that's for sure. All around him is a variable failings of Uber's black shirted millennials. But Greg speaks fluent trucker, Black shirted millennials. But Greg speaks fluent trucker. And so he pulls out his phone and shows me Okay, another middle-aged guy and yet another fedora. So here it is opens up. How to use the Uber Freight app
而我现在就在这里。现在格雷格，你有一个独特的故事，因为你是一名老卡车司机。没错，完全正确。你已经成为了 Uber 的公共关系联络人，是这样的吗？没错，我称之为卡车运输界和 Uber 货运（Uber Freight）之间的翻译官。格雷格温和可亲，正值中年，留着盐和胡椒色相间的胡须，戴着一顶酷炫的费多拉帽。比起电脑操作员，他更像个卡车司机，这是肯定的。他的周围是一群身穿黑色衬衫的 Uber 千禧一代。但格雷格精通卡车司机的黑话。穿着黑衬衫的千禧一代。但格雷格精通卡车司机的黑话。于是他掏出手机展示给我看。好吧，又是一个中年男人，又戴着一顶费多拉帽。所以它打开了。如何使用 Uber Freight 应用程序
And it knows that I'm in Louisville today, so now it's thinking about it and so it has these little cards for each load, right? So instead of connecting cars with riders, freight is connecting trucks with loads so read that off to us Greg if you would so this one is from Walton, Kentucky to Los Alamos California for 3,070 that's the price for this load. It's 1800 miles. It has a type of trailer, the load number and all that. What it is, the weight. All I have to do is tap that card and the load is mine. No phone calls, no haggling. Technology is coming and we need to embrace it and be part of the conversation.
它知道我今天在路易斯维尔，所以现在它正在思考，因此它为每笔货运都有这些小卡片，对吧？因此，货运不是将汽车与乘客联系起来，而是将卡车与货物联系起来，所以格雷格，如果你愿意的话，给我们读一下这个——所以这个是从肯塔基州沃尔顿到加利福尼亚州洛斯阿拉莫斯，价格是 3,070 美元，这是这趟货物的价格。有 1800 英里。它有拖车的类型、货运编号诸如此类的东西。它是什么，重量。我所需要做的就是点击那张卡片，货物就是我的了。没有电话，没有讨价还价。技术正在到来，我们需要拥抱它并成为对话的一部分。
I have to wonder though, at 3,000 bucks on a state of distance of 1800 miles, does it no haggle simply mean take it or leave it? You have no choice. I'm just going to confess to you, there is a primal fear about the power of a company like this. I think change overall is just difficult for people to embrace. It's unfamiliar. We don't know what it's going to look like Change overall is just difficult for people to embrace. It's unfamiliar. We don't know what it's gonna look like
不过我不得不怀疑，在 1800 英里的路程中，价格为 3,000 美元，这无讨价还价是不是简单地意味着要么接受要么拉倒？你别无选择。我不得不向你坦白，对于这样一家公司的力量，有一种原始的恐惧。我认为总的来说，人们很难去接受改变。它是陌生的。我们不知道它会变成什么样。总的来说，人们很难去接受改变。它是陌生的。我们不知道它会变成什么样
and that creates anxiety. That said, truckers are embracing new technology and using it for their own benefit. I got the team. You've got quite a hat collection. Well, way back when I gave myself heatstroke by being stupid. Take Sandra Goshi. Basically, you tell them how the people treated you if you were professional, if there was
这会产生焦虑。话虽如此，卡车司机们正在拥抱新技术，并利用它来为自己谋利。我得到了那个团队。你真有不少帽子。嗯，很久以前，我因为太愚蠢而让自己得了中暑。以桑德拉·戈什（Sandra Goshi）为例。基本上，你告诉他们人们是如何对待你的，如果你很专业，如果有一个
a bathroom that you could use because there's a lot of places that don't allow truckers to use their bathroom. She's telling me about Doc 411. It's a reading app basically like Yelp for loading docs. You kind of help the trucker after you or the person after you. They've surveyed over 10,000 truckers about their experiences. Sunder here is doc 411's number one reviewer. If they have four clips that you use four clips, what are some of the other attributes Stephen that you can rethink of?
你可以使用的洗浴室，因为有很多地方不允许卡车司机使用他们的洗浴室。她正在跟我讲 Doc 411。它是一个评价应用程序，基本上就像是货运月台的 Yelp。你有点像是在帮助你后面的卡车司机或你后面的人。他们对10,000多名卡车司机进行了关于他们经历的调查。桑德在这里是 Doc 411 的头号评论员。如果他们有你使用的四个夹子，斯蒂芬，你还能重新考虑哪些其他属性？
If there's overnight parking, if you can sleep there and the overnight parking, Sunder drives as a team with their husband, Steven. That's right, journalism, how you were treated professional. If I was to read the review that I put in for this one doc, I would never take freight into this doc. We went in there the first time and we waited three hours to get unloaded, which that's okay. Second time we went in there, we waited 13 hours.
如果有夜间停车位，如果你可以在那里睡觉以及夜间停车位。桑德和她的丈夫斯蒂芬组队驾驶。没错，新闻业，你是如何受到专业对待的。如果我要阅读我为这个特定月台发表的评价，我绝不会把货物运进这个月台。我们第一次进去的时候，等了三个小时才卸货，这还算可以。我们第二次进去的时候，等了13个小时。
No bathrooms, no facilities, and couldn't leave the truck. If you used like that or add it up and turned into a scorecard for every dock they do business with. Doc 411, it's one of those things that it's like, it's never going to be complete because there's always going to be new docs, but it's going to be a big relief to all of us truckers. But there's still another technology on trucker's minds that mats this year. Right now, that e-log.
没有卫生间，没有设施，而且不能离开卡车。如果像那样使用或者加起来，就会变成他们开展业务的每个月台的记分卡。Doc 411，它是那种永远不会完成的东西，因为总会有新的月台，但它对我们所有的卡车司机来说将是一个巨大的解脱。但今年在 Mats，卡车司机心里还有另一项新技术。现在，那就是电子日志。
Something much more consequential than a new app. Electronic log situations become a pretty big issue. It's called an ELD. The new ELD mandate has electronic logging device. We're still needing e-log versus e-log. Most of the time, we didn't have e-log. That's the biggest thing. Take the sea log and shoot. And ain't right with me no more.
比一个新应用程序重要得多的东西。电子日志的情况已经变成了一个相当大的问题。它被称为 ELD。新的 ELD 强制令配备了电子记录设备。我们仍然需要电子日志与电子日志的对比。大多数时候，我们没有电子日志。那是最大的一件事。拿下海上的日志然后开枪。这对我来说再也不合适了。
This e-log issue is all playing out right now. And it's pretty much the biggest change that's come to our culture. At least since I started trucking. And ain't right with me no more. Hundreds of big rigs to go for highway 99. At least since I started trucking. Hundreds of big rigs to go over highway 99 in protest today creating a show. Some truckers have even put on protests about EODs. Right here guys, 95 southbound is shut down. It's one of those things that just keeps coming up in our conversations with drivers.
这个电子日志问题现在正在上演。这几乎是我们文化中发生的最大变化。至少自我开始开卡车以来是这样。这对我来说再也不合适了。数百辆重型卡车驶过 99 号公路。至少自我开始开卡车以来是这样。今天数百辆重型卡车在 99 号公路上抗议，造成了一场展会。一些卡车司机甚至对 ELD 进行了抗议。就在这里，伙计们，南向 95 号公路已经关闭。这是在与司机的对话中不断涌现的事情之一。
So on our first day at Mance, we find ourselves at the vintage Maroon Peter Bell. I'll sit down, I guess that'll work, is that all right? Someone who's been at the center and of so much of the protest. Yeah, so my name's Mike Landis from Littitz, Pennsylvania, a little Amherst Country Town, a Lancaster County. I got into trucking right out of high school pretty much. I got my CDL after I graduated. First time I got behind the wheel at the driving school
所以在 Mats 的第一天，我们发现自己来到了那辆复古的褐红色彼得比尔特（Peterbilt）卡车旁。我坐下吧，我想这行得通，这样可以吗？这个处于抗议风暴中心并经历了如此多抗议的人。是的，我叫迈克·兰迪斯（Mike Landis），来自宾夕法尼亚州利蒂茨（Lititz），一个安默斯特的小乡镇，兰卡斯特县（Lancaster County）。我高中一毕业基本上就开卡车了。我毕业后就拿到了 CDL。第一次在驾校坐上驾驶座
at the local vote tech, it was all downhill from there. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
在当地的职业技术学校，情况从此急转直下。是的。是的。是的。是的。是的。是的。是的。
Elogs are all about how truckers record their driving and working hours. So yeah, we have what they call our hours of service, which is once you come on duty, you're allowed 14 hours of working time. 11 of that 14 can be driving, but then you have to take 10 hours off before you can go back to work. So every day you get 14 hours on duty and you have to take 10 hours off. Problem with that is, is that once you start your day,
电子日志完全关乎卡车司机如何记录他们的驾驶和工作时间。所以，是的，我们有所谓的服务时间，也就是一旦你开始工作，你就有14个小时的工作时间。这14个小时中有11个小时可以用来开车，但接着你必须休息10个小时才能回去工作。所以你每天有14个小时的执勤时间，并且必须休息10个小时。其中的问题在于，一旦你开始了一天的工作，
your clock for the day doesn't stop. Now in the past, those hours were recorded in paper logbooks. Every driver kept a set of books in the cab, recorded their time with a pen on a four-line grid, and made that log available to inspectors and state patrol. Basically, you regulated yourself. So to me, that's important because I was taught the old way of trucking. You do what you got to do to get the job done, but you sleep when you're tired, and you
你一天的计时就不会停止。过去，这些时间是用纸质日志记录的。每个司机在驾驶室里都备有一套日志，用钢笔在四线网格上记录他们的时间，并将该日志提供给检查员和州巡警。基本上，你是自我监管的。所以对我来说，这很重要，因为我是按照卡车运输的旧方式被教导的。你做你必须做的事来完成工作，但你累了就睡觉，而且
know, you truck when you're awake. If you took a quick nap in your shift or ran a little over the time limit, you could juggle that. Clarically I mean. You don't turn into a zombie just because your five minutes passed your time and fall asleep and drive off side of the road. That is, you could juggle it until the electronic logging device. And basically what that does is it hooks into the computer on the motor of the truck. And basically what that does is it hooks into the computer on the motor of the truck and it records everything you do You know how hard you're on a throttle how hard you're on the brake if you're moving if you're stopped your speed the whole nine yards
你知道，你清醒的时候就开车。如果你在轮班期间小睡了一会儿或者稍微超过了一点时间限制，你可以灵活处理。我是说在纸面上。你不会仅仅因为超出了五分钟就变成僵尸，然后睡着并把车开到路外面去。也就是说，你可以灵活处理，直到电子记录设备的出现。基本上它的作用是连接到卡车发动机上的电脑
It counts down every second of your day So whereas before on a paper logbook if you're five minutes past your time pulling a truck stop Nobody knew the difference, no harm, no foul. But now, I mean, I've seen people back halfway in a parking spot and trucks stops already because if they finish backing up, they're yielding, I'll put them in violation
并且它记录你所做的一切，你知道你踩油门有多猛，踩刹车有多猛，你是在移动还是停下来，你的速度，方方面面。
to go another 50 feet back to truck up in no parking spot. Yeah, you hear stories like this all the time. Truck speaks like whales in the most god awful places because their drivers ran out of hours. You've probably seen those trucks yourself. That's because in December 2017, a new mandate came into effect requiring virtually all trucks on the road to run an electronic log.
它倒计时你一天的每一秒。因此，而在过去使用纸质日志时，如果你在卡车休息区超出了五分钟，没有人会注意到区别，没有伤害，没有违规。但现在，我的意思是，我已经看到有人在停车场倒车倒了一半，而卡车休息区已经满了，因为如果他们完成倒车，他们就会违规，这会让他们因为再倒车 50 英尺停进一个没有停车位的地方而违规。是的，你一直都能听到这样的故事。卡车像鲸鱼一样停在最糟糕的地方，因为他们的司机耗尽了工时。你可能自己也见过那些卡车。那是因为在 2017 年 12 月，一项新的政令生效，要求路上几乎所有的卡车都必须使用电子日志。
And to me, it's a slap in the face. Driving a truck at 18 years old, I'm now 33, closing them on 2 million miles, I have a clean driving record. To me, that all comes down to the way I was taught. That comes down to the responsibility of knowing you're operating an 80,000 pound machine. The fact that they're going to tell me that I need this thing in my truck to keep me safe on the road doesn't sit well with me at all. Well, I hear you loud and clear.
对我来说，这就像是一记耳光。18岁开始开卡车，我现在33岁，即将达到200万英里，我有干净的驾驶记录。对我来说，这一切都归结于我被教导的方式。这归结于知道你在操作一台80,000磅重的机器的责任感。他们告诉我我的卡车里需要这个东西来保证我在路上的安全，这让我感到非常不舒服。好吧，我听得清清楚楚。
We do these Texas, Ohio, Texas, Florida triangles a lot. Denise's stepmother is dying. She's in a Louisiana nursing home. And we want to see her. She's days away from dying, literally days away from dying. And I'm on the NLD. We stopped to see her. And essentially, we've got to say our goodbyes to her
我们经常跑德克萨斯、俄亥俄、德克萨斯、佛罗里达这样的三角形路线。丹尼斯（Denise）的继母快要去世了。她在路易斯安那州的一家疗养院里。我们想去看她。她离死只有几天了，简直离死只有几天了。而我正在使用 ELD。我们停下来去看她。基本上，我们得和她道别
in about 45 minutes because our 14 hour clock is ticking. And I just have this moment of complete clarity that something's got to give. Yeah. And there's a lot of people that will say, Hey, that's not true. They don't force you to drive tired. They don't force you to not take a shower. Yada, yada, yada. Well, I mean, you're right. The thing doesn't reach up and grab me and tell me I need to keep trucking, but the sad reality is, is they kind of do. Now I should say here that Mike does not run a knee log. The reason my truck don't need one is because the cutoff date
大约 45 分钟，因为我们的 14 小时计时器在滴答作响。我当时有一种彻底清醒的时刻，觉得必须有所妥协。是的。有很多人会说，嘿，那不是真的。他们不强迫你疲劳驾驶。他们不强迫你不洗澡。等等等等。好吧，我的意思是，你是对的。那东西不会伸手抓住并告诉我需要继续开车，但残酷的现实是，它们确实有点那样。现在我应该在这里说明，迈克没有使用电子日志。我的卡车不需要它的原因是因为截止日期
is 2000 and newer need them and 99 in order do not. So it's 99 Peter Belt is just too old to connect to a computer, but Mike has done more than just avoid the new regulation. It's actually fighting it. So we started the United States Transportation Alliance and the unique thing about us is that all of us are drivers that met through doing protest type stuff for the industry. And nobody out here that is making these rules or regulations or pushing for rules or regulations have ever sat behind the wheel for any amount of time and definitely not any time recently. So, you know, when we go to DC and we go every month right now, you know, we park our trucks,
是 2000 年及更新的车型需要它们，而 99 年及更早的则不需要。所以这辆 99 年的彼得比尔特（Peterbilt）太老了，无法连接到电脑，但迈克做的事情不仅仅是避开新法规。他实际上在与之抗争。所以我们成立了美国交通联盟（United States Transportation Alliance），我们独特的地方在于，我们所有人都是通过为这个行业做抗议类事情而认识的司机。外面的任何人，无论是制定这些规则或法规的人，还是推动制定规则或法规的人，都从来没有在驾驶座上坐过哪怕一小段时间，更不用说最近的任何时间了。所以，你知道，当我们去华盛顿特区时，我们现在每个月都去，你知道，我们把卡车停好，
we meet with congressmen and senators and FMCSA. That's the federal motor carrier safety administration. Truckload carriers, we've met with the teamsters. It's been a pretty good thing and we were fortunate enough to Help with the hours of service that are supposed to be changed. I'm actually expecting an announcement here at mats for that In fact the keynote speaker for the weekend is none other than a lane chow the United States secretary of transportation So we're hoping that it has to do something with that. I realize things change with the times and technology goes and the snap the other thing,
我们与国会议员、参议员以及 FMCSA 会面。那是联邦汽车载运安全管理局（Federal Motor Carrier Safety Administration）。卡车运输公司，我们已经和卡车司机工会（Teamsters）会面了。这是一件相当不错的事情，而且我们很幸运能够协助修改本应更改的服务时间。我实际上在 Mats 期待着关于这方面的公告。事实上，这个周末的主题演讲嘉宾不是别人，正是美国交通部长赵小兰（Elaine Chao）。所以我们希望它与此有关。我意识到事情随着时代和技术的发展而改变，等等，
but trucking is still trucking. And I chose me personally. I chose to drive a truck because I grew up around trucks and I love trucks. And for me, you know, it sounds kind of corny, but the other week I was invited to a concert by someone that we know backstage and stuff afterwards were hanging out. And like watching this guy up on stage, you could tell he was just in his zone. And I said, the best way I could describe watching you on stage is like me riding across the California Arizona desert with a truck pressed out in the moon lit and a chicken lights on it's pipe singing and dry, you know cruising and some people are like what I don't get it
但卡车运输仍然是卡车运输。我个人选择了。我选择开卡车是因为我是在卡车堆里长大的，我热爱卡车。对我来说，你知道，这听起来有点老土，但上周我被我们认识的人邀请去后台看演唱会，之后我们在那里闲逛。就像看着这个家伙在舞台上一样，你可以看出他完全进入了自己的状态。我说，我能形容看你在舞台上的最好方式，就像我开着卡车穿越加利福尼亚和亚利桑那沙漠，卡车在月光下飞驰，烟囱上挂着小鸡灯，歌唱着并干燥着，你知道巡航着，有些人会说，什么，我不明白
You're just driving a truck down the road and I'm like yeah, but to me it's more than just driving a truck down the road You know It's the freedom of it and that's kind of being taken away. It's what the bad part is. You know, if we don't do anything to help fight this stuff, guys like me are going to be gone. After the break, we'll hear that big announcement from Elaine Chao. But first we venture out onto the parking lot at Matt's. We'll hear why this e-log thing is such a big deal, and I'll tell you what gave for me.
你只是在路上开卡车，而我说，是的，但对我来说，这不仅仅是在路上开卡车，你知道，那是自由感，而那正在被剥夺。这才是糟糕的部分。你知道，如果我们不采取任何行动来帮助抗争这些事情，像我这样的人就会消失。休息过后，我们将听到赵小兰（Elaine Chao）的那个重大公告。但首先我们冒险来到 Mats 的停车场。我们将听到为什么这个电子日志事情是如此大的一件事，我会告诉你对我来说发生了什么。
And how ELD's led, at least indirectly, to the making of this podcast. You're listening to Over the Road on 99% of us. Here again is Over the Road. Hey folks Todd Dills here. I'm the senior editor with Overdrive Magazine, which is helping to produce this podcast. For those of you who are new to this trucking world, Overdrive is basically a trade publication for independent truckers, ones who own the rigs they haul with. For many years, we've called ourselves the voice of the American trucker, and so part of what we wanted to do with this podcast was to actually build a little bridge between the highway haulers who read overdrive and well, they initiated among you.
以及 ELD 是如何至少间接地促成了这个播客的制作。你正在收听 99% 的我们带来的《在路上》。再次为您带来《在路上》。嘿，伙计们，我是托德·迪尔斯（Todd Dills）。我是《超速》（Overdrive）杂志的高级编辑，该杂志一直在协助制作这个播客。对于你们这些卡车运输界的新人来说，《超速》基本上是针对独立卡车司机的行业出版物，他们拥有自己用于运输的卡车。多年来，我们一直自称为美国卡车司机的声音，所以我们想通过这个播客做的事情的一部分，就是在阅读《超速》的公路货运司机和你们这些初学者之间建立一座小桥梁。
So I'm going to be hosting a special series of mini episodes where I'll take questions from those of you outside the business and put them directly to our trucking listeners. We're calling it the channel one nine special after the CB radio channel used for trucker to trucker information sharing. The first channel 1-9 episode will show up in your feed next week, but I'm dropping in now to ask a quick favor. If you've got questions about trucking seriously, about anything at all, having to do with it,
因此，我将主持一系列特殊的迷你剧集，我将收集你们这些行业外人士的问题，并将它们直接抛给我们的卡车司机听众。我们将其命名为“19号频道特别节目”，以用于卡车司机之间信息共享的 CB 无线电频道命名。第一个 19 号频道剧集将在下周出现在你的订阅源中，但我现在插播一下，请求帮一个小忙。如果你对卡车运输有疑问，说真的，关于它的任何事情，
no question is too simple or too strange. Give us a call at 765-245-4844, and leave us a call at 765-245-4844 and leave us a message. Again, 765-245-4844. Be sure to state your name and location with your question and thanks. Okay, so back to the Mid-America trucking show. I want to pick things up the next morning outside in the parking lot where drivers are busy polishing their trucks. I love trucking though. It's a lifestyle. It's not a job.
没有哪个问题太简单或太奇怪。给我们打个电话 765-245-4844，并给我们留个言 765-245-4844。再次拨打 765-245-4844。请务必在你的问题中说明你的姓名和所在地，谢谢。好的，那么回到美国国际卡车展。我想在第二天早上在室外的停车场继续进行，那里的司机正忙着擦拭他们的卡车。不过我热爱卡车运输。这是一种生活方式。这不是一份工作。
It's a lifestyle. There are actually two parking lots of trucks at each with its own vibe. There's the show lot and the Papa John's lot. We'll explain why it's called that in a minute. But the show lot is home to the Paul K. Young Truck Beauty Championship. And that's where we start our day. My name is Debra Jones. I'm working on excessive behavior. Number one. My name is Eric Turner. Name of my truck is Showtime.
这是一种生活方式。实际上有两个卡车停车场，每个停车场都有自己的氛围。一个是展览停车场，一个是棒约翰停车场。我们一会儿会解释为什么叫这个名字。但展览停车场是保罗·K·杨卡车选美大赛（Paul K. Young Truck Beauty Championship）的发源地。我们的一天就是从那里开始的。我叫黛布拉·琼斯（Debra Jones）。我正在致力于纠正过度行为。第一名。我叫埃里克·转纳（Eric Turner）。我的卡车名字叫秀场。
Get your boots fresher down here for your turbo. No, you want to check out my scrap boot? Check this out. This is a place where trucks have names. The goose is a 1996 freight liner classic exhale. It's this part of the family. The goose is my big girl, filises my little girl. They're fastened with those little amber bulbs
在这里把你的靴子为你的涡轮增压器擦干净。不，你想看看我的废品靴吗？看看这个。这是一个卡车有名字的地方。大雁（The Goose）是一辆 1996 年的福莱纳经典豪华型（Freightliner Classic XL）。这是家庭的一部分。大雁是我的大女孩，菲利斯是我的小女孩。它们用那些被称为小琥珀灯泡的东西装饰着
we call chicken lights. Every truck driver wants chicken lights, and they won't crawl. White carpeting, wood floors. It's actually just a wooden floor that you get it from a home deeper. Really? Yes, sir. It's actually just a wooden floor that you get it from a home depot. Really?
我们称之为小鸡灯。每个卡车司机都想要小鸡灯，而他们不会爬行。白地毯，木地板。实际上，这只是你可以从家居建材店买到的木地板。真的吗？是的，先生。实际上，这只是你可以从家居建材店买到的木地板。真的吗？
Yes, sir. For the competition itself, trucks are organized into different sections marked off with plastic rows. There are categories like antique custom, limited mileage bob tail, working class bob tail, and working combo. Meaning, I put miles on my truck. My favorite? The Antique Original.
是的，先生。对于比赛本身，卡车被组织成用塑料绳标出的不同部分。有古董定制、有限里程短途卡车、工作车班次短途卡车和工作组合等类别。意思是，我在我的卡车上跑了里程。我最喜欢的？古董原版。
I cut my teeth on one of these trucks. This is a transstar international. There's nothing like the AM radial reception on an all steel-made old school western start. The Old school western style. There are teams who work an entire year to prep a truck for this show. I've seen guys polish on it for a day and a half and they're still rubbing now. You gotta live it, love it, breathe it, bleed it.
我从这些卡车中的一辆开始接触这个行业。这是一辆国际跨星（Transstar International）卡车。全钢制造的老派西部之星（Western Star）上的 AM 无线电接收效果是无可比拟的。老派西部之星风格。有一些团队花了一整年的时间为这个展会准备一辆卡车。我见过有人擦了一天半，现在还在擦。你必须体验它，热爱它，呼吸它，流血它。
If you believe, as I do, that a truck can be a work of art, then this is the Guggenheim. There's a lot of history there, a lot of our life has been spent in it, under it, over it. Everything in the squirrel, no to a cherry, we've done it this trouble. How much would you have to have for this truck right now? 200 green. What sort of installment plan would you consider? No, we can do that. Thanks for your time, that. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
如果你像我一样相信卡车可以是一件艺术品，那么这里就是古根海姆博物馆。这里有很多历史，我们的很多生命都是在它里面、下面、上面度过的。松鼠里的一切，小樱桃，我们都用这辆卡车做过了。这辆卡车你现在得要多少钱？20万美元。你会考虑什么样的分期付款计划？不，我们做不到那个。谢谢你的时间，那个。对不起。对不起。
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。
对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm more of a Papa John's type. This lot serves the University of Louisville football stadium, formerly known as the Papa John Stadium. The university dropped that name after the pizza magnaid found himself in hot water, but for truckers, the shorthand stuck. In any case, picture a stadium parking lot with rows upon rows of tractor trailers.
对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。我更喜欢棒约翰类型的。这个停车场服务于路易斯维尔大学美式足球场，以前被称为棒约翰体育场。在该披萨大亨陷入丑闻后，大学去掉了这个名字，但对卡车司机来说，这个简称留了下来。无论如何，想象一下一个体育场停车场，里面停满了成排的牵引车拖车。
Only thing is, these aren't show trucks. These are just the trucks people drove here to attend. They're all out here now with their camping chairs, gas grills, and coolers walking their dogs in the Kentucky spring air. It's maybe the biggest tailgate in all of trucking big enough that you can actually lose your truck in it. At the show lot I didn't see a single person I knew, but down here in Stereage, it's different. How are you doing, Debbie? I'm digging that new chrome bumper.
唯一的问题是，这些不是展览卡车。这些只是人们开车来参加展会时开的卡车。他们现在都带着露营椅、燃气烤架和冷却器，在肯特基春天的空气中遛狗。这也许是整个卡车运输界最大的露营尾随派对——大到你实际上可以在其中迷失你的卡车。在展览停车场，我没有看到一个我认识的人，但在底层的露营区，情况则不同。你好吗，黛比？我很喜欢那个新的镀铬保险杠。
I won't tell you what happened to the last one. Was it a deer? No, it was a fence. I bet. Why remember that? I bet it jumped out. It was just a bit annoying. You know what, no promise being us in the back of my head.
我不会告诉你上一个怎么了。是一只鹿吗？不，是一扇栅栏。我敢打赌。为什么我记得那个？我敢打赌它是跳出来的。只是有点烦人。你知道吗，没有保证在我的脑后。
Later that night, there's even an impromptu concert. Let's get back to it now. And guess who gets invited to sing? I got any flat betters out there, any flat betters, okay great. Yeah, and yet another side gig, I'm a singer-songwriter. When we had a friend, he felt deeply in love with a female flatbedder. But when she learned that he pulled a reaper, she rejected him, because he didn't know how, you know,
那天晚上晚些时候，甚至还有一场即兴音乐会。我们现在回到正题吧。猜猜谁被邀请唱歌？这里有任何平板车司机吗，任何平板车司机，太好了。是的，还有另一个副业，我是一名唱作人。我们有一个朋友，他深深地爱上了一位女性平板车司机。但当她得知他拉的是冷藏车时，她拒绝了他，因为他不知道如何，你知道的，
the chains and the binders. And it's called, I'll never run that back door anymore. Well, she dollied down and dropped me low. I've been like a nascar porn took her tin and put it in the wind. Since you couldn't live with the guilt of what we done in that Peter building, I'll never run that back dog in. In a way, conscious like this or a reenactment of a bygone age. And drivers would be laid over at some truck stop. Someone would bring out a grill. Someone would contribute a case of beer.
链条和紧固器。这首歌叫做《我再也不会跑那辆后门车了》。好吧，她放下支腿把我拉得很低。我一直像一辆纳斯卡赛车，拿走她的罐头并把它放进风里。既然你不能带着我们在那辆彼得比尔特卡车上所做之事的内疚活下去，我将永远不会再跑那辆后门车了。在某种程度上，像这样的集会是对过去时代的重演。司机们会在某个卡车休息区逗留。有人会拿出一个烤架。有人会贡献一箱啤酒。
Someone might commandeer a chicken or two off their load. And someone, I'd just have a guitar. She said, Paul, it ain't no use. You're a door-sweaker. I ain't going to live this life. Maybe that's why this e-log thing is such a big deal. Because there just doesn't seem to be time for those encounters anymore.
有人可能会从他们的货物中征用一两只鸡。而有人，我只会拿着一把吉他。她说，保罗，没用的。你是个开门司机。我不会过这种生活的。也许这就是为什么这个电子日志事情是如此大的一件事。因为似乎再也没有时间进行那些相遇了。
And maybe that's why I still come back here to hear the stories, the stories that seduced me into this life so long ago. Yeah, I started driving in 88, all out of Mississippi furniture. That same night we talked to a guy named Tim. And they would tell you right quick life. If you cannot turn 5,000 miles a week, we don't need you. We've got a stack of applications over here this day. We can replace you tomorrow.
也许这就是为什么我仍然回到这里来听这些故事，那些在很久以前诱惑我进入这个生活的故事。是的，我从 88 年开始开车，全部运送密西西比家具。那天晚上晚些时候，我们和一个人交谈，他叫蒂姆。他们会很快告诉你生活。如果你不能在一周内跑完 5,000 英里，我们就不需要你。我们这里有一大叠申请表。我们明天就可以替换你。
And of course, then you take note. I would take a gram of good crank note and I would do a line every three or four hundred miles. And for some there really was this dark side to the old days. I mean, taking whatever drugs you could take to stay awake. Stories like this of trucking's wilder days really aren't that hard to come by around here. We would stop exit 30 and Tennessee, exit 200, and for some reason, now, more than ever, I think.
当然，接着你会注意到。我会服用一克好的冰毒，每三四百英里我会吸一条。对一些人来说，旧日子里确实存在这种黑暗面。我的意思是，服用你能服用的任何药物来保持清醒。像这样关于卡车运输更疯狂日子的故事，在这里确实并不难找到。我们会停在田纳西州的 30 号出口，200 号出口，出于某种原因，现在，比以往任何时候都更甚，我想。
We've been heard it onto the digital reservation of the E-Log. It's like we have to tell these stories. I remember one time, I went all the way to Boston. I'm trying to get through traffic, trying to get back. Massachusetts State Police pulls me over. He passed my pockets. I had on cargo paths. The bottle was down at the bottom of it. He missed it. I could have got years in the penitentiary then. So I go down to the restaurant in Rhode Island and I celebrate not doing me two lines of note just to get on back. But then it wasn't to get high. It was to do a job.
我们被赶进了电子日志的数字保留地。就像我们不得不讲述这些故事一样。我记得有一次，我一路开到了波士顿。我正试图穿过交通，试图赶回去。马萨诸塞州州警拦下了我。他拍拍我的口袋。我穿着工装裤。瓶子就在底部。他漏掉了。我当时可能要在监狱里度过好几年。所以我去罗德岛的一家餐厅庆祝我没有吸两行冰毒来赶回。但那不是为了嗨。那是为了工作。
It was for your work. It wasn't recreational. Turned it miles. Turn it burned, man. How did you get off of that stuff? There's three ways you get off a crank. Math. Jail, the grave, or Jesus. I was in Amarillo and I'd been up two or three days and I prayed God you know help me. I'd been up two or three days and I prayed God you know help me and he spoke to me He said it's up to you It's through the grace of God that I got off of it So You're now you're off the crank. Yes. We've prayed God's intervened
那是为了你的工作。那不是娱乐性的。跑里程。烧里程，伙计。你是怎么戒掉那种东西的？你戒掉冰毒有三种方法。戒毒所。监狱、坟墓或耶稣。我在阿马里洛（Amarillo），我已经两三天没睡觉了，我祈祷上帝你知道帮帮我。我已经两三天没睡觉了，我祈祷上帝你知道帮帮我，他对我说一切由你决定是靠着上帝的恩典我才戒掉它的所以你现在已经戒掉冰毒了是的。我们祈祷上帝干预了
What do you tell your boss that needs 5,000 miles a week out from you? Tell them I can't do it anymore, I work for myself. I'm an owner operator now. You owner operator now. Thank God he delivered me from that aspect too. Now, I work when I want to. Thank God I've been delivered. I got my first ELD back in 2016. A few months after that watermelon rack I told you about in Knoxville, the fleet I worked
你对那个需要你一周跑 5,000 英里的老板说些什么？告诉他们我再也不能那样做了，我为自己工作。我现在是一个车主运营商。你现在是车主运营商了。感谢上帝他也把我从那个方面解救出来了。现在，我想什么时候工作就什么时候工作。感谢上帝我已经得救了。我在 2016 年拿到了我的第一个 ELD。就在我之前跟你提过的诺克斯维尔那个西瓜车祸几个月后，我工作的车队
for announced that we would roll out an e-log pilot program. Guinea pigs were needed. Something about Knoxville jared me more than it should have. For years I had pushed myself to the limit as a produce hauler and had never been bothered by the what-ifs. But after Knoxville it just seemed like my nine lives were up. At that time, the e-log felt like kind of a way out of all that. So I let Brenda our safety officer know I would give it a try.
宣布他们将推出一个电子日志试点项目。需要小白鼠。诺克斯维尔的事情比它应该给我的震撼更大。多年来，我作为农产品运输司机把自己逼到了极限，从不为那些“万一”而烦恼。但在诺克斯维尔之后，似乎我的九条命已经用尽了。当时，电子日志感觉像是摆脱这一切的一种方式。所以我让我们的安全官员布伦达（Brenda）知道我会尝试一下。
Yep, that's right folks. I volunteered. When the day came, they trained me on how to operate the e-log, which recorded the truck's data straight onto a basic Samsung tablet. The company told me not to go crazy on Netflix, and all I went. Since I was now carting around this brand new tablet and I started recording some of my songs and posting them on YouTube. The song came to me in a dream. You know something like this. I also began writing about my experience of being an old trucker who had to make the
是的，没错，伙计们。我是自愿的。当那一天到来时，他们培训了我如何操作电子日志，它将卡车的数据直接记录在一个基础的三星平板电脑上。公司告诉我在 Netflix 上不要疯狂，而我都照做了。既然我现在随身带着这台全新的平板电脑，我开始录制我的一些歌曲并将它们发布到 YouTube 上。这首歌是在一个梦中来到我这里的。你知道类似这样的话。我也开始写关于我作为一个不得不进行
e-log switch. I mostly did this as a cathartic exercise, but on a whim I sent some of these ramblings to an editor at Overdrive Magazine named Todd Dills. You heard from Todd earlier. I can't make it to the next day. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy.
电子日志切换的老卡车司机的经历。我这样做主要是一种宣泄练习，但出于一时兴起，我将其中一些胡思乱想发给了《超速》（Overdrive）杂志的一位名叫托德·迪尔斯（Todd Dills）的编辑。你刚才听到了托德的话。我无法坚持到第二天了。我不会成为一个好人。我不会成为一个好人。我不会成为一个好人。我不会成为一个好人。我不会成为一个好人。我不会成为一个好人。我不会成为一个好人。我不会成为一个好人。我不会成为一个好人。
I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy.
我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。
I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to be a good guy. I'm not going to E-Logs. But enough about me.
我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会当个好人。我不会去搞电子日志。但关于我的事就说这么多。
All weekend, drivers are waiting for that big update that Mike was telling us about on the new rules for e-logs. What we call, hours of service. Yeah, we've had a few people sign up to be members and stuff so far while we've been here. Mike Landis even has a booth set up on the showroom floor of Matt. He dropped a couple thousand dollars out of my own company to build the booth and we trucked it here and stuff like that. floor of mats. He's got a whole crew here dressed in their matching black shirts. You know, to get the word out there and show people who we are and what we're doing and what better place to do it where there's thousands of truck drivers at one spot, you know. It's been a year now since the ELD mandate went into effect and we're all feeling it in one way or the other. into effect and we're all feeling it in one way or the other. So we sit through long seminars by government administrators. But no news. Then on our last day at Matt's,
整个周末，司机们都在等待迈克之前告诉我们的关于电子日志新规则的重大更新。也就是我们所说的服务时间。是的，到目前为止，在我们在这里的时候，我们已经有一些人注册成为会员之类的了。迈克·兰迪斯甚至在马特的展厅里搭建了一个展位。他从我自己的公司里掏了几千美元来建造这个展位，我们把它用卡车运到这里等等。马特的展厅地板。他带了一整支队伍来到这里，穿着配套的黑衬衫。你知道，为了把消息传出去，向人们展示我们是谁，我们在做什么，还有什么地方比成千上万的卡车司机聚集在一个地方更适合这样做呢。距离电子日志强制令生效已经一年了，我们都以这样或那样的方式感受到了它的影响。生效了，我们都以这样或那样的方式感受到了它。所以我们听取了政府官员的长篇大论。但没有任何消息。然后，在我们离开马特的最后一天，
Transportation Secretary Elaine Chow gets up to give us the keynote address. If the DOT has something to say this would be the time but right away the power goes out. Eventually the power comes back. Welcome to my home town. I hope you really love your stay, and the wine is fed lots and lots of money. And she gets to what we're all waiting to hear. So I'm pleased to announce today that the department is moving forward with the next step, which is a known certificate for the role-making regarding our service of rule.
交通部长赵小兰上台发表主旨演讲。如果交通部有什么要说的，现在就是时候了，但电源马上就断了。最终电源恢复了。欢迎来到我的家乡。我希望你们真的喜欢你们的逗留，这里的美酒有着源源不断的资金。然后她讲到了我们都在等待听到的内容。所以我很高兴今天宣布，部门正在推进下一步，也就是关于我们服务规则的规则制定的已知证书。
So I can't go into the details, but let me note that the department understands. Still nothing, no news. It's the flexibility and is getting into serious consideration. Just then, an alarm sounds. Someone trying to tell us something. Instead, the speech turns to the usual pleasure. Tell us something. Hey, don't wanna let me tell you this good news! I'm not gonna hear you. I'm not gonna hear you. Instead, the speech turns to the usual platitudes.
所以我不能透露细节，但请让我指出，部门是理解的。依然什么都没有，没有消息。灵活性正在被认真考虑。就在这时，警报声响起。有人想告诉我们一些事情。相反，演讲转向了平常的客套。告诉我们一些事情。嘿，别想不让我告诉你这个好消息！我才不想听你讲。我才不想听你讲。相反，演讲转向了平常的陈词滥调。
You are the lifeblood, what makes our commerce work. I'm so tired of that line. You enable bread to appear on our own sweet shells. Blah, blah, blah. And we want to thank you, Ford, America, for coming to us. And without really seeing much of anything at all, Elaine Chow, Bidzah Saul, farewell. We're going to see her back for the rest of us.
你们是命脉，是让我们的商业运作的动力。我太厌倦那句话了。你们让面包出现在我们自己的甜蜜货架上。等等，等等。我们要感谢你们，福特，美国，来到我们这里。赵小兰在没有真正看到任何实质内容的情况下，向比扎·绍尔道了别。我们将会在接下来的时间里再次见到她。
Thank you so much. The Minimeraque Trucking Show closed the next day. The show trucks drove out in formation while the Papa John's lot gradually disbanded. Matt's was done. But we're just getting started. We're going to keep following this ELD issue across the series. We'll hear how Mike Landis brought his fight to the streets of Washington, D.C. and found unlikely allies in the process. Where some context will go deep into the history of trucking with one of my favorite writers.
非常感谢。麦格纳卡车展于第二天闭幕。秀车排成队驶出，而棒约翰的停车场逐渐解散。马特展会结束了。但我们才刚刚开始。我们将在整个系列节目中继续关注这个电子日志问题。我们将听到迈克·兰迪斯是如何将他的斗争带到华盛顿特区的街头，并在过程中找到了意想不到的盟友。在某些背景下，我们将与我最喜欢的作家之一深入探讨卡车运输的历史。
We'll hang out at truck stops and meet the families of truckers to understand how this business affects the people around us and will peer into a future where the trucks may just drive themselves. But first we're going to Grand Island Nebraska to find out why anyone would want to drive a truck in the first place. I was intrigued and so I called her up and I said no. Now come again about the truck driving. Now what did you say? Thanks to everyone who entrusted us with their stories. We'll catch you again over the road.
我们将驻足卡车停靠站，走访卡车司机的家庭，去了解这一行业如何影响我们周围的人，并展望未来卡车或许能够实现自动驾驶的前景。但首先我们要去内布拉斯加州的格兰德岛，去弄清楚为什么会有人想要开卡车。我很感兴趣，于是我打电话给她说，不，关于开卡车这事你再重新说一遍，你刚才说了什么？感谢所有向我们吐露心声的人。我们在路上再会。
Mama said to me, son, you know you can become whatever you want to be. So by my old graze with brown, it hurts me somehow. For her to see what became of me. See it, 19 years old, I was restless and bold in the highway. Call me one day. Now it's down on my blood and it rolls like a flood. And it takes everything, it's way. Now I'm working blood and it rose like a flood and it takes everything that's way Now I'm working on over the road
妈妈对我说，孩子，你知道你可以成为你想成为的任何人。所以靠着我年迈的棕色双亲，这在某种程度上让我感到痛心，让她看到我变成了什么样。看吧，十九岁的时候，我在高速公路上浮躁而大胆。有一天召唤了我。现在它流淌在我的血液里，像洪水一样翻滚，带走了一切，这就是它的方式。现在我正在路上努力工作，它像洪水一样汹涌，带走了一切，这就是它的方式，现在我正在路上工作。
Over the road Working on over the road Over the road It takes a lot of people to make a podcast And I'm going to tell you about all of them Our Our Over the Road Pick Crew includes producer and sound designer Ian Koss and contributing producer Lacey Roberts at Transmitter Media. Our editor for Overdrive Magazine is Todd Dills. Our digital producer is Erin Wade.
在路上，在路上工作，在路上。制作一档播客需要许多人的努力，我要向你们介绍他们所有人。我们的“在路上”制作团队包括Transmitter Media的制作人和声音设计师伊恩·科斯（Ian Koss），以及特约制作人莱西·罗伯茨（Lacey Roberts）。《Overdrive》杂志的编辑是托ッド·迪尔斯（Todd Dills）。我们的数字制作人是埃林·韦德（Erin Wade）。
Our project manager is Audrey Mardovitch and our executive producer for Radiootopia is Julie Shapiro. I'm Long Homopall. All the music on the show is by Ian Koss and myself, featuring performances by Travis the Snakeman Womack, Terry Tussox Richardson, the late great Roger Clark, Jan Gullet, Jim Whitehead, and Andrew Marshall, additional engineering by Donny Gullet and Muscle Shoals, Alabama. Special thanks to these drivers and vendors whose voices you heard throughout, JD Howard of the Ohio Great Lakes Regions, Atlanta-based small fleet owner operator Eric Turner,
我们的项目经理是奥黛丽·马多维奇（Audrey Mardovitch），Radiotopia的执行制作人是朱莉·夏皮罗（Julie Shapiro）。我是隆·霍莫帕尔（Long Homopall）。节目中的所有音乐都由伊恩·科斯和我本人创作，其中有特拉维斯“响尾蛇”沃马克（Travis the Snakeman Womack）、特里·塔索克斯·理查森（Terry Tussox Richardson）、已故伟大的罗杰·克拉克（Roger Clark）、简·古利特（Jan Gullet）、吉姆·怀特黑德（Jim Whitehead）和安德鲁·马歇尔（Andrew Marshall）的表演，阿拉巴马州肌肉群岛的唐尼·古利特（Donny Gullet）提供额外工程支持。特别感谢以下在节目中出声的司机和供应商，俄亥俄州五大湖区的JD·霍华德，亚特兰大小型车队车主兼经营者埃里克·特纳（Eric Turner），
Daniel and Phyllis Snow of the Goose Freightliner Classic, Chad Boblin from Kentucky Horse Country, Robert Pong, creator of truckersfinalmile.org, Christopher Burnett of Burnett Farm toys, and Debbie Dingo Deserado. They also heard from Devery Jones, Jason Earlywine, James Reigns, Bobba Davis, fellow singing truckers, Brad James, Taylor Barker, and the Jake Break Chunky himself, Terence Mathis. Over the road is made possible by support from the folks I've worked for for a really long time. Moller trucking. Now celebrating over 30 years of safe and reliable transportation for the food industry. Report from the folks I've worked for for a really long time. Molar trucking.
“鹅”号福莱纳经典车（Goose Freightliner Classic）的丹尼尔和菲利斯·斯诺（Daniel and Phyllis Snow），来自肯塔基州跑马之乡的查德·博布林（Chad Boblin），truckersfinalmile.org的创始人罗伯特·庞（Robert Pong），伯内特农场玩具的克里斯托弗·伯内特（Christopher Burnett），以及黛比·丁戈·德塞拉多（Debbie Dingo Deserado）。大家还听到了德弗里·琼斯（Devery Jones）、杰森·厄尔利温（Jason Earlywine）、詹姆斯·雷恩斯（James Reigns）、博巴·戴维斯（Bobba Davis），以及同为唱歌卡车司机的布拉德·詹姆斯（Brad James）、泰勒·巴克（Taylor Barker）和“杰克刹车”大块头特伦斯·马西斯（Terence Mathis）的声音。《在路上》得以呈现，离不开我共事了很长时间的莫勒货运公司（Moller Trucking）的支持。该公司现在正在庆祝为食品行业提供安全可靠运输服务超过30年。感谢我工作了很长时间的莫勒货运公司。
Now celebrating over 30 years of safe and reliable transportation for the food industry. For more information check out molartrucking.com. Over the road is a collaboration between Overdrive Magazine and PRX's radio topio, a collection of the best independent podcasts around. I've turned a lot of overnight reefer loads listening to shows like the Memory Palace and Criminal. Seriously, find out more about the whole network at Radiotopia.fn. www.patreonline.com Be sure to follow us on all those usual platforms too, Facebook, Twitter and Instagram, and
现在正庆祝为食品行业提供安全可靠运输服务超过30年。欲了解更多信息，请访问 molartrucking.com。《在路上》是《Overdrive》杂志与PRX旗下Radiotopia的合作项目，Radiotopia汇集了周围最好的独立播客。听着诸如《记忆宫殿》（The Memory Palace）和《罪案》（Criminal）这样的节目，我度过了许多开夜车拉冷藏货的时光。说真的，请在 Radiotopia.fn 或 patreon.com 了解关于整个网络的更多信息。也请务必在所有常见的平台上关注我们，Facebook、Twitter、Instagram 以及
over-the-road pod. You can see some of my videos on YouTube by looking for long haul, haul music. Thanks for listening, and hanging in till the end of the run. We'll be back next week with a channel 1.9 special, then in 2 two weeks with morein' over the road Over the road, workin' over the road Over the road, workin' over the road Over the road, workin' over the road It's like a watermelon. You can have as a friend. It's like a watermelon. You can have as a friend. You can have as a friend. You can have as a friend. No, no, that's great. You can have as a friend.
over-the-road pod。你可以在YouTube上搜索 long haul haul music 来观看我的一些视频。感谢您的收听，并坚持到了这段旅程的最后。我们将在下周带着1.9频道特辑回归，然后在两周后带来更多“在路上”的内容。在路上，在路上工作。在路上，在路上工作。在路上，在路上工作。它就像一个西瓜。你可以把它当成朋友。它就像一个西瓜。你可以把它当成朋友。你可以把它当成朋友。你可以把它当成朋友。不，不，那太棒了。你可以把它当成朋友。
No, no, no, no, no. Go watermelon. You can have as a friend. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不，不，不，不，不。去买个西瓜吧。你可以把它当成朋友。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。